the gyro can experience you know for
he's like 17 like an ex-convict he looks
good was playing golf all day was it
it's all he does even like Tom Tom plays
golf it looks great
he seems to have at least a slight
struggle with communicating right and
walking he seems like he's got a little
slowness to his voice
we're just forcing it you know I mean
which is probably CTE
oh is that CT yeah but he sounds pretty
clear pretty clear pretty clear yeah
there's a there's a hint there's a hitch
you know you get it you see it in
fighters or just there's a yeah right
now because it might just be you're
tired right I'm thinking yes but there's
some days where I'm jet-lagged or tired
I'm just really stupid okay I don't talk
that good he also like you know he did
beat two murder cases that'll make you
loose you know
mady's yeah 70s right isn't he yeah he's
in a 70s and like still there's there's
a fizzle there's a struggle stretch
slight struggle to the way who's talking
that makes me think he's dealing with
some Sparks OJ Simpson worried he has
CTE I have days that I can't find words
yeah 100% the CT makes you murder people
right that's just I mean you could be I
mean is that what that would use that
today Oh Jay that's what his lawyer had
said no really one of his lawyers had
said that had owed Jay Simpson but it
was a lawyer or was it a medical advisor
me medical advisor said I would bet my
bento client that he has CT
yeah but he was also saying that it
would have been a part of the defense
right it would have been a part of the
crime had happened today I mean that's
what I'm saying right that's why but
Aaron Hernandez they were saying dude
with all of them yeah and obviously
you're in a super violent sport too yeah
most violent and then too
you're gonna you're gonna have a high
capacity for violence right yeah you
know I mean that it does and then on top
of that if you're you're [ __ ] wirings
you've been smashed so many times and
they do get smashed and they're wiring
does go for some of them fighters and
haywire yeah they get a little haywire
Chris Benoit yeah that was
that that that kind of [ __ ] is so
terrifying
I could kill his family I mean and many
people that have experienced extreme CTE
have wound up when they committed
suicide donating their brain saying um
you know like that one dot dude junior
junior seau he shot himself in the chest
right so that they could look at his
brain that's hard man that's hard I mean
that how many fights have you been in
that many times you've been concussed I
don't know I don't know how many times
I've been concussed um I've never been
knocked unconscious but I got a tko'ed
in a kickboxing match the last fight I
ever had
I got cracked I had crack with a left
hand it was like it was one of the
weirdest times I've ever been hit
because I had been I definitely been hit
hard before but had never been hit where
my legs stopped working I just stopped
they just stopped like he hit me he
caught me like right at the tip of my
jaw with like a left hook that I didn't
see coming and my leg just went
whoopsies they just gave out they gave
out like they said is shut off there's a
nerve in here you're saying that's kind
of like you get hit and your jaw goes
sideways and your head twists and your
brain sloshes around in there yeah and
it's like a bolt of electricity it's
like it's like everything shuts off just
shuts off but I was still conscious but
I was like oh [ __ ] what is going on here
like this is crazy and I was like
alright get back up your feet so the
referee was counting he got to eight or
something like that I got up to my feet
they dusted my gloves off and the kid
came at me again and hit me with an
uppercut and another punch and dropped
me again then they stopped the fight so
I was never unconscious but that was the
worst I'd ever been like beaten in a
fight we're just cool sandwiches the
swords flying but that was the last time
I ever fought but other than that there
was a lot of like training sessions
where you get kicked in the face or
punched yeah there's a lot of those yeah
just just happens most of the time you
know if you get hit full blast it's an
accident can you get tested for CTE is
that I think that's a test there's no
agency they have tests
did a few people while they're alive
they have an extra brain to find the
stuff so there's no hole in your brain
yet to prove to like have undone because
you got to die first
yeah the they like to do autopsies on
people with CTE and they crazy
atrophied brains right a brain of an 85
year old person with with Alzheimer's
disease it's really nuts man like their
brains are [ __ ] up there's all these
weird proteins get developed from the
concussions yeah [ __ ] like with like
that calcifies the brain or something
does horrible things eats away different
parts of the brain there's like these
little dark spots and holes right
exactly sure what the mental processes
but the the medical process is rather
but it sounds like it does like dead
spots like your brains dead days when
they always just great they okay former
NFL player can defend his first
diagnosis of CTE and living patient yeah
we talked about this before everything
so they're able now to get some sort of
an accurate run out of what your brain
looks like and they can see the CTE
without having to open you up but I
think most of time it's when a person is
already dead maybe their their detection
methods are getting better listen man if
you look at that brain go back to that
role that image when the guys poking at
the brain and he's looking at the x-rays
or the the MRIs look at look at this
look at that just look at that thing the
Hat which is protected by a thin layer
of bone is where all of your [ __ ]
thinking takes place all of it it's an
organ and you get punched in the face
all of that is just but like detaching
from the walls all the connective tissue
what does that stuff called that that
that real weird stuff that sits between
what kind of connective tissues that
describe does between the brain and the
skull there's like a specific name for
it Oh like that that that then later
yeah and that stuff gets ripped oh
that's yeah
here is free and your [ __ ] it's when you
get hit you're saying yeah sometimes
people develop internal bleeding after
fine sighs Jesus there yeah combat
sports crazy I mean it's you it's your
weight another guy just died right
another boxer another boxer two boxers
died in a very short period of time yeah
some people think that they should
shorten fights now but they should make
them like eight rounds
what could guys are just bigger and
faster and stronger I mean just people
just want to mitigate the thing the
damage right mitigate the damage but
maybe if you did that in the high-level
fights you'd miss amazing fights right
like Deontay Wilder and Tyson Fury if
that wasn't 12 rounds when when Wilder
knocked him down the 12th round and
fewer gotta dead we would have missed
one of the greatest moments in the
history of the sport I mean that was an
amazing moment man for two reasons one
is how [ __ ] hard Deonte punches yeah
and to that Wilder who looked like he
was dead to the world rises up and then
out boxes them for the rest of round
survives survives Wilder chasing them
down and then out boxes him then even
tags Wilder has Wilder too covering up
that whole round doesn't take place if
you only fight ain't round cuz opposed
be a test of endurance too right not
just strength and power for sure yeah I
mean maybe if people were only fighting
eight rounds it would be worse because
they would go harder exactly that's what
I'm saying yeah yeah and there'd be more
fights because yeah you exert all your
energy in the first three four three
five rounds the only argument against
that those kickboxing cuz in kickboxing
they've always had less rounds like
kickboxing like a Muay Thai fight a lot
of times they'll fight three rounds or
they'll fight five rounds yeah but that
I never I mean come on I mean cuz that
that's yeah that like that's insane I
mean you talk about tree trunks hang
somebody you know what I mean so awful
yeah that should only be three to five
[Applause]